they weren't upset that his name was out
there they're upset that it's another
Muller you know that I get into so much
in the book you know it's it's the
Muller investigation you know when he's
an innocent public servant he's beyond
reproach he's just a nice guy when he's
a CI a gay guy with ties went to Biden
when he's in the photo crying you see
that this is this is not an objective
unbiased person this is the swamp at its
finest the leaker yes now right now I
know that we're doing this on YouTube
this is a live stream if we name the
leaker even though the name is out there
you're they are most likely gonna shut
this stream they might shut this stream
anyway just because we're now talking
about it but the leaker it's been named
in a zillion things on a zillion outlets
it was or it's already been on
television Facebook has said they're
taking down content with the leakers
name YouTube's been taking down live
streams they did a big one last night
that they took down so I'm just gonna
read you the the statement on this and
then we'll talk about it the best way we
kind of ran here right so a YouTube
spokesperson said videos mentioning the
potential whistleblowers name would also
be removed the spokesperson said that
the company would use a combination of
machine learning and human review to
scrub the content I'm pretty sure we're
getting both of those right now the
removals the spokesperson added would
affect the titles and descriptions of
videos as well as the videos actual
content so look I don't want this video
to be taken down but they're obviously
watching it right now the name is out
there there's a picture of this person
on the White House lawn the day your dad
showed up at the White House re-election
I was it's interesting I've gotten to be
a part of the outrage cycle it's a very
fast line yeah what we've been on here
for about ten minutes I'm sure that the
cycle of outrage has changed and as
adapted to something else since we've
been on but you know I was part of the
outrage so I guess last week because I
apparently outed the whistleblower even
though it was all over the internet I go
like you know i retweeted an article
that literally had his name in the title
of the article yeah it was on the Drudge
Report you know the view goes like the
drummer who knows about the drugs before
I go like I don't know it's like the
largest news aggregator anywhere in the
world
probably right I mean I was on The
Drudge Report four days prior to that it
was in RealClearPolitics so I put it out
there Donald Trump jr. outside like I
didn't like I still don't know his last
name was like most I was just retweeting
the article I could care less but I
realized pretty quickly it wasn't so
much day that they were outraged that I
had outed him it's that now that if
there are the name is known people can
actually do some research right it's
that's what I wanted he's a humble
public servant who's just trying to do
what's right for that now he's a CIA guy
who was Biden's guest at a state dinner
who was good friends with Brennan
apparently who was in the photograph as
you mentioned you know the day my father
its president-elect and going to the
White House crying like a little child
you know in the group picture where
everyone's so morose and they're all
wearing black and you know they're in
mourning yeah because it's the end of
their world as we know it was Susan Rice
or whoever else was in the picture like
they're like yeah that guy he's gonna be
super objective he's just a homo buddy
you know this didn't start his lawyer
doing tweets you know in January of 2017
right after the inauguration the coup
has started impeachment is next you know
right along with the stuff that looks
awfully like really weird child stuff
yeah oh yeah yeah there's nothing wrong
with these people
you know that's the point they weren't
upset that his name was out there
they're upset that it's another Muller
you know that I get into so much in the
book you know it's it's the Muller
investigation you know when he's an
innocent public servant he's beyond
reproach he's just a nice guy when he's
a CI a gay guy with ties went to Biden
when he's in the photo crying you see
that this is this is not an objective
unbiased person this is the swamp at its
finest this is the deep state guy that
wants to help out his people and they
will do whatever they can to attack
Trump because Trump is going in and
breaking up their cabal their system
that they've built up for so long that
they know and love that hasn't made all
their friends really rich and that's a
problem for them so let me ask you a
question as a guy that punches back do
you think I'm basically sort of half
step in this year by not saying his name
I mean I'm tempted to say his name no
I'm not you know that matters because
anyone can go on right now and just type
it in and figure it out for themselves
so I'll rather can
you know frankly keep the platform but
again the whole point you don't need to
ruin my what's not yeah let's give them
a little bit more yeah but I mean it's
it's so much a part of the book which is
you know that social media censorship
it's like they have decided like the
mainstream media to be the marketing arm
of the Democrat Party how do you think
they coordinated so like something like
this where it's so everything that you
just said is correct the picture is
there like obviously all the connections
and and no one wants anything bad to
happen to this guy but but the reason
they don't return hey Alyssa I wish they
would have shown the same you're
endangering his life I'm endangering the
guy life of a CIA I wish I would have
seen one percent just one percent I
don't need it all over the same amount
of outrage when like right you know my
wife opened up an exploding pout we a
white powder envelope of people that was
a Warren volunteer none of that stuff
comes out like that's at my house that
way my kids like that doesn't deserve
outrage but this guy that's working in
the deep state he's a CIA guy he needs
our protections like give me a break
like come on I'm not advocating for
violence of anyone but at least at least
balance this thing out in terms of that
and so it's sort of you know that
outrage cynical just shows exactly what
we're up against do you think your dad
always saw that thing like that sort of
protection racket between the Democrats
and the media yeah it seems like he
always kind of knew how to play the
media better than him
you know when he was in his career and
you know I talked about in the book you
know when we went down to launch the
campaign and it was I guess you know
June 16 2015 I mean the last thing he
said to us one before he walked over to
go to the elevator and we went down to
go watch was just look this now we find
out who our real friends are and so he
knows he understands the real world he
understands how it works he understands
how full of crap most people really are
you don't I mean like everyone's looking
for an angle and honestly politics is no
different if anything it's probably
worse in that effect meaning you're
great and you're useful until you're not
and you know the thing that is missing
so much is loyalty and it's it's you see
it and so he's always known and we've
always known that the media has been
left-leaning it's just now that they've
given up the pretense of even object
I mean you know you see that the
Washington Post you know the day after
the the inauguration oh sorry 19 minutes
after the inauguration 19 minutes yeah
wrote the first article the case for
impeachment the 19th minute
that's about the amount of time that
Obama took to get nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize right they in fact
that was 11 days I believe but like yeah
that's the difference right so when I
certain when people would have had the
impeachment that started last week I go
in start last week it started on
November 9 2016 okay the day they knew
he had won that's when this thing
started and you know again if you
weren't a believer in the deep state
prior to his you know election I get it
you know if you aren't now you're a
freaking idiot can you do people say
deep state and then you know sudden
Twitter's gonna explode in conspiracy
theories you basically mean sort of the
layer that always exists because that's
kind of what right but have my sheet of
the habilitation you know essentially
manipulating you know the people's
choice I mean you know Donald Trump was
elected by the people of the country
this is the unelected you know
self-appointed leaders of this country
you know if they disagree with the
president who was elected to do you know
the things that he campaigned on well
we're just gonna do that because we know
better and it's in that class it's that
elite and honestly you know that's
always existed but I think you know now
that that class has not only just
existed but they've become nefarious you
know they're they are doing whatever
they can to not only just you know do
their little thing but subvert the
actual will of the people and that's
where it starts getting scary do you
think your dad was the only guy that
could break this cuz the you know
there's a lot of metaphors for this so
there's a lot of analogies you know some
people say he was the ice breaker that
was gonna break it so I I would say
always saying that it was just the chess
board he was the guy that was just like
you're all playing this fake game we're
gonna toss it up see what had it's
probably a combination of the both I
mean I think the reality is if you look
at sort of some of the major examples of
his presidency I mean you know take
Kavanagh right how long do you think
like let's say like a Jeb Bush character
you know under fire you know
unfounded ridiculous allegations about
gang rape magically appear you know it I
know you know yeah how long do you think
Jeb would have lasted when the media
took the sound bytes that they wanted
really this definitely happened a hard
person like we're never gonna quest it
second maybe two yeah like that's where
I'd set the over-under before he folded
it would have went over 19 minutes it
wouldn't have made it 19 minutes and so
you know Donald Trump just isn't gonna
you know buy into the nonsense he isn't
just gonna cave to that kind of pressure
and that's exactly what we need today
because we need a really reset you know
this whole thing and so he is the
perfect vessel for this and so that's
why well people well you know it's
pretty aggressive like you've been under
attack for three years I mean I I see a
lot of moderate you know Democrats did
get honestly like I'm a Democrat but
like I wish they just let him do his job
I mean he's accomplished things that
prior Probot in the job numbers where
they are had he done the things for the
african-american community like prison
reform opportunity zones they would have
knighted him you know Emperor for a life
he's doing this racist thing wrong I
mean he's like the worst races ever
because he's failing miserably yet I
mean if you're gonna fail at something
it's great to fail at being racist
pretty much yeah but it's such nonsense
I see that because I see it from the
characters I mean you know Whoopi
Goldberg we used that example she can't
say his name well didn't stop her from
showing up but one of the finales of The
Apprentice of hanging out with us at an
after-party five six years ago whenever
that was now she was there she didn't
have a problem with us then that was
another thing I could have brought up
had you know the whole I mean there's
just so many examples of this you didn't
stop al Sharpton from saying all these
complimentary things Reverend Jesse
Jackson for saying hey he gave us based
on a wall street building when we
weren't you know when we weren't
anything I know you know I have pictures
with half of the resistance like at
dinner right so that's what your dad
meant by that we're gonna find out who
our friends are correctly had
connections with everybody in that or
done so much and you know that's the
reality I mean you know when Al Sharpton
needed a place to stay in New York it
was one of the stories in the book like
he literally called me to set him up
with a broker to get help get him a
place it wasn't this hatred so like
he'll Jill go over friend of musn't like
it it's all an act if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell